What is this place?
It's the everything factory, silly.
It’s good to see you, Joseph. How are you?
Yeah, man! Really good!
Hey, I wanted to tell you because we haven’t had a
chance to speak face to face,
how good you are in Wolfboy, man.
Your performance is really good.
I thought that went very well!
You too. Luxcraft was absolutely incredible.
Why that’s brilliant!
Whew!
So there’s some pretty cool questions they’ve printed
on these nifty Wolfboy cards.
Should we dive into these?
Oh yeah, I have some too.
We’re going on an adventure!
What is imagination in your eyes?
My mom was just reminding me that she used to find me
playing alone in my room with all kinds of
just made up characters and stories and stuff,
and she would ask me what I was doing,
and I would say I’m playing with my imagination.
That was not the answer I was expecting.
(Laughing)
What do you do to get your creative juices flowing?
I just like sitting down in my armchair and just
staring at a drawing pad thinking,
what can I draw?
What could be cool?
So you draw? I didn’t know this about you.
Yeah, I like to draw quite frequently.
It’s pretty much the best way to
get what you see in your mind out.
Yeah!
If that makes sense.
That makes perfect sense.
It’s, it’s one of the creative skills
I’ve always wanted to spend more time with.
Mmm, I see we have some work to do
What is an idea that no one else has come up with yet?
Ooh ooh, I have an idea
Great!
A time traveling elevator? Or a magical slide!
It’s a clock that can rewind time,
so if you miss your alarm,
you can just pull back the clock handle and rewind time.
So you never end up being late.
I need that for sure.
(laughing)
Such little respect for time!
What’s the strangest dream you’ve ever had?
I was in the ocean,
and for some reason, I could just tell I was a fish.
Yet, I still had human arms and legs.
Mhmm.
And then I found some other fish and
I then started talking to them for some reason.
Do you remember the conversations?
It sounded like English, but for some reason,
everyone else was speaking in like,
just, they were just going--
(fish noises)
I don’t even know how that happened.
It was so weird.
(laughing)
It’s all a dream!
How much fun was it playing Professor Luxcraft?
I had so much fun playing Luxcraft.
Cool!
As an actor, one of the big thrills for me
is getting to play somebody that’s different from myself.
Luxcraft is this like big guy with a huge, purple beard
and he can do magic and he’s so wise.
Be one with the wisps.
Let them connect to your creativity.
Over the course of playing him,
I sort of found things about him like,
oh, actually, that’s sort of like me.
Being an artist is sort of like being
a wizard in certain ways.
I knew it! I knew it! Ha ha!
When people watch Wolfboy and the Everything Factory,
what is it that you hope they get out of it?
One of the best parts about playing Sprout was
the message he was bringing out to people,
which is do not let your fears control what you do
and I found that very helpful.
Just be yourself. Make us proud, okay?
(babbles)
It’s a real pleasure talking to you.
Yeah, it was absolutely amazing finally getting to meet you.
I hope to see you again soon.
Alright, thanks Archie. Good talking to you, man.
Alright. Bye Joseph!